[музика]
Щиро вітаємо вас Ми раді що ви дивитеся
Нашу програму Європа висихає за даними
комісії Європейського Союзу Це ймовірно
найсильніша Засуха за останній 500 років
і вона вже залишила глибокі шрами в
багатьох регіонах
найдовша річка Німеччини стає всевущою
Рейн страждає від неймовірної нестачі
води для економіки - це драматична
ситуація до своїх перевезень вантажні та
екскурсійні судна можуть рухатися лише в
заглибленому форматері
насправді рендія гордістю німецького
річкового ландшафту його називають
батьком Так тут не вспіли жодну іншу
річку поети зокрема гейдерін та Гейне
присвячували йому свої вірші але дедалі
спекотніше літо призводить до того що
найважливіший водний шлях Німеччини з
роками дедалі більше втрачає розміри та
велич коли річковий рух зупиняється
через низький рівень води велика частина
вантажних перевезень на цій зазвичай
могутній річці і зупиняється наш
Репортер зустрівся на реані з людьми які
вже тривалий час відчувають на собі
наслідки
історично низький рівень води місцями
глибина рейну не досягає навіть метра
більше нічого не працює у
західнонімецькому місті альтріп за те що
впродовж уже кількох днів вода для
пороми сімейного підприємства занадто
мілка вода не рівня одного метра 30 см
тож ми переїжджаємо наше судно не
проходить все Ти застряг вальці і двигун
вийшов із ладу новий такий двигун коштує
майже 270 тисяч євро як я вже казав
просто так його не купиш тепер частина
працівників повинна піти у відпустку
інша працює неповний робочий день решта
двома екскаваторами купають новий
глибший фарватер униз по рейну у порту
мангейма стає зрозуміло скільки
поставлено на карту по річці
здійснюється 80% німецького річного
судноплавства директор Порту уветіон
каже нам що від доставки товарів водним
шляхом залежить багато галузей економіки
ви бачите там попереду як поліція
потребує один із двох проходів під
мостом ймовірно тому що там уже
недостатньо води і ви бачите як два
кораблі намагаються тепер обережно
проїхати один повз одного Тож у хлопців
справді важка робота бо Важливо щоб
нічого не трапилося але найбільшу
проблему на думку у векена видно на
прикладі цього вантажного судна кораблі
більше не можна завантажувати повністю
тож для транспортування тієї самої
кількості що і при нормальному рівні
води потрібно Наразі у 3-4 рази більше
вантажного простору це призводить до
дефіциту і звичайно До Зростання ціни і
це велика проблема але особливо шкідлива
екстремальна посуха на рейні для
навколишнього середовища хирардо унгер
лафуркад понад 10 років спостерігає тут
за природним ландшафтом зараз тваринний
і рослинний світ знаходяться під
серйозною загрозою
тут ми як правило були на метр під водою
але зараз тут просто немає води
тож і не все живе що не може відступити
це стосується передусім дрібних тварин
зокрема равликів мідій або ракоподібних
Утім Як каже природоохоронець зараз стає
небезпечно і для риб
тут уже все вимерло такі калюжі можете
собі уявити вони нагріваються до 35
градусів
це мертві зони не тільки для риби але
для всіх мікроорганізмів
до всіх бід додаються ще й туристи які
сприяють подальші загибелі флори та
фауни багато хто використовує низький
рівень води щоб дійти до всесвітньо
відомої мишачою вежі через це як каже
еколог знищується цінні місця виведення
пташенят
Отже проблема з людьми на таких
недоступних островах полягає в
руйнуванні
якщо він не звик до того що там ходять
люди то кожна людина яка там тиняється
буде величезною перешкодою з якою птах
може не впоратися
і Тому поки не свою вкладку
Ми їдемо далі повздовгій піщаній мілини
зупинені кораблі та річку вода в якій
мілка як ніколи майже всі промні
переправи через зупинення однак Мартін
шнаус у містечку інгельгайм ще якось
працює у п'ятому поколінні упродовж 130
років його сім'я здійснює перевезення
через Рейн на своєму поромі він ще
працює бо його порогом спеціально
розроблений для екстремального
мілководдя
наш двигун знаходиться над нижче Корабля
А це означає що внизу пором плоский і не
побудований на тілі тут ще достатньо
повітря тому вода ще може опуститися на
півметра Сподіваюся до цього не дійде
дуже сподіваюся
Тож у ці дні справи У Мартіна шнаса
йдуть Добре від його пороми тепер
залежить Усе більше пасажирів і туристів
раніше так було кожні 20 років але тепер
це стабілізувалося таким чином що ти
більше не можеш плавати тут кожні два
роки принаймні інші не можуть тому ми
зараз допомагаємо
до дна річки у пороми ще залишається 50
см але навіть Мартін шнаас не знає чи
надовго цього вистачить якщо найближчим
часом не піде дощ доведеться зупинитися
мабуть і йому
війна в Україні стає все бруднішою
бомби Путіна падають на житлові квартали
влучають у лікарні вбивають таранять
найслабших хворих людей
українець Павло ковтунюк поставив перед
собою завдання задокументовувати ці
руйнування він хоче притягнути
російських агресорів до відповідальності
за ці звірства
згідно з українськими даними від
російських ракет постраждало майже 700
закладів охорони здоров'я два з них у
Чернігові що на півночі України далеко
від лінії фронту
коли він ще був заступником міністра
охорони здоров'я Павло ковтунюк
намагався реформувати українську систему
охорони здоров'я тепер через три роки
він документує її знищення колись Це був
центр серця у Чернігові у березні він
був повністю знищений під час нальоту
російської авіації один із понад 180
нападів на заклади охорони здоров'я які
задокументували ковтунюк та його
неурядова організація
ми бачимо тут систематичне руйнування
системи охорони здоров'я як частини
базових умов життя цивільного населення
адже йдеться не лише про систему охорони
здоров'я
такої також і різні цивільні об'єкти
цей момент зафіксував відеореєстратор
тоді 8 російських бомб влучили у
житловий квартал свідок надсилає нам
інше відео на ньому видно руйнування
всього через кілька хвилин після удару
чітко видно діру прямо перед центром
серця
у результаті нападу загинули 407 осіб
десятки отримали поранення у ці дні
Чернігів знаходився під постійним
обстрілом розповідає нам одна мешканка
могили довелося копати екскаватором
жертву було так багато що їх доводилося
ховати у мішках для трупів
за однозначними показаннями свідків
поблизу лікарні Не було жодних
військових об’єктів чи позицій
тому в його очах напад є воєнним
злочином каже ковтунюк За який Росію
слід притягнути до відповідальності
лікарні - це місця які військові повинні
оминати а не бомбардувати а потім казати
Ой вибачте Це була лікарня Ні вони
повинні переконатися що там немає
лікарні А якщо і є То вони повинні
зробити все можливе щоб її не зачепити
це їхній обов'язок згідно із женевською
конвенції
щоб справа зрештою дійшла до
звинувачення зараз Вони намагаються
зібрати якомога більше доказів
на місці ковтунюк та його колеги
спілкуються зі свідками шукають сліди
ударів та залишки боєприпасів і вони
прискіпливо документують усі завдання
збитки
Вони працюють за міжнародними
стандартами пояснює ковтунюк щоб їхні
докази могли використовувати суди в
усьому світі
у нас немає юридичної підготовки у
жодного з нас
ми є експертами і з охорони здоров'я але
ми дещо дізналися про порядок дій під
час навчання ми робимо усе що можемо і
сподіваємося що принаймні деякі з наших
доказів приймуть і Зрештою вони
допоможуть у звинуваченні злочинців
його неурядова організація
задокументувала також і справу
Чернігівської дитячої лікарні Ми
зустрічаємося із лікарем Миколою
Людкевича перш ніж ми поставили йому
будь-яке запитання він одразу починає
говорити про те як вони лікували
багатьох постраждалих Під час обстрілу
житлового масиву і як через два тижні
бомба потрапила вже в їхню лікарню
під час війни то тільки книжки а коли в
реалії коли всі в крові розірвані з
численними ранами переломами
з криками стонами і діти і дорослі
бабусі і ми виклали наприклад отак 5 а
їх ще поступають і через постійні
обстріли їм знову і знову доводилося
тікати в підвал іноді там навіть
оперували вони робили все можливе аби
захистити своїх маленьких пацієнтів
російська ракета оснащена забороненими у
світі касетними боєприпасами удар
пошкодив будівлю із першого по п'ятий
поверх перед цим була повітряна тривога
і Всі встигли заховатися підвал і тому
якби вийшли всі діти то ми розуміємо що
237 вікна це могло би 237 жертв а він
показує нам уламки шрап Нелі які зібрав
на місці їм довелося оперувати годинами
розповідає він Щоб дістати десятки таких
уланків і стіл дітей
розріз зробити довгооперувати
коли ти це чуєш то не потрібно
пояснювати Навіщо нам справедливість
адже Хтось має заплатити за те що
зробили з такими людьми як Микола та
його пацієнти
коли ми залишаємо Чернігів то
проїжджаємо повз ще одну повністю
зруйновану лікарню Ковтонюк знає що
минуть роки і перш ніж міжнародні суди
зможуть а висунути звинувачення але до
того часу він хоче зробити все можливе
щоб зафіксувати докази
перша така звичайна родом з центральної
та східної Європи цей Хижак має дві
дивовижні та загрозливі властивості він
чудово плаває Та може здолати кілька
кілометрів У гонитві за здобиччю зокрема
вівцями
А ще шакал ненажерливий
Ось чому пастухам доводиться боротися з
ним тепер і тут на хорватському
архіпелазі коронати у прекрасних
природних заповідниках досі шикарів там
не було А ще ця тварина має неймовірно
хороший нюх
увесь ранок як і в шиківч провів у
дорозі щоб знайти принаймні кілька своїх
овець Вони живуть на півдику і
розосереджені на острові кішкера
Сьогодні він хотів їх постригти але все
що він приносить додому це ягня
абсолютно налякане та апатичне
[музика]
як і живе зі своєю сім'єю на курнатах
архіпелаг є природним раєм і вже понад
40 років національним парком
століттями люди жили тут із рибальства
вівчарства та оливок
крихка екосистема які раптом загрожує
новий ворог
на острові з'явилися шакали вовкоподібні
дикі собаки
за ними слідкує златку ружанович біолог
національного парку
випадково він тут саме в цей день ще два
дні тому розповідає йому Яків біля
будинку була пара овець зі своїми
ягнятами
скільки є чому два тижні А чому один
годинник
і тут було ще одне ягня разом із цим
також однотижневе але воно зникло обоє
зникли Ось це я знайшов сьогодні вранці
Яків краще виростити ягня вручну ніж
залишить його шакалом адже на овечій
вовні він нічого не заробляє він може
продавати лише ягнят
Вони поставили пастку на фермі Якова
спроба хоча б що-небудь зробити але поки
безрезультатно пастка порожня
не підходить
ми спробуємо ще десь
але Яків каже що вона замала
подивися вхід занадто малий
шакали лякливі і кмітливі і майстерно
маскуються завдяки своєму хутру златку
бачить тварин лише за допомогою відео
пасток
але це важко спекотно острови непрохідні
щоб розташувати камери у потрібному
місці знадобиться як удачу так і навички
а потім йому доводиться повертатися
кожні 2-3 тижні щоб поміняти батарейки
та переглянути знімки
тут ми намагаємося з усіма камерами
з'ясувати скільки їх у якому напрямку
вони рухаються та з якої інтенсивністю
тобто Як часто вони тут з'являються
тут біля єдиного водопою на всіх
корнатах шанси хороші сюди приходять
вівці але також і шакали
це слід хороший
ось шакал А ось вівця
обої були біля водопою
однак зараз вони загрожують життю овець
які потрібні для того щоб рослинність на
острові залишалася короткою
особливо під оливковими деревами ці
дерева не росли як слід якби земля під
ними заростала
ми у дорозі з патрулем адміністрації
парку тепер вони регулярно організовують
полювання вони убили також і кількох
шакалів але тварини все одно поширюються
островами поки що Рейнджери точно не
знають Чому вони підозрюють Що це Через
вплив навколишнього середовища
з південного боку дуги отока
позаду нас маленький острів Велла Альба
тому проходив або ми вважаємо що шакал
приплив сюди на Корнати з дуги отока
через вела альбу загалом це десь 800
метрів
і ми знаємо з літератури що шукали мужик
легко проплисти дві милі аби більше
і справді є відео яке записали місцеві
жителі
шакал спокійно пливе до берега на
курнатах ніколи раніше не було шакалів
тепер їхні сліди можна знайти всюди
з'являється все більше фотографії
мертвих овець
не всі я жертвими шакалів але більшість
3 години три роки тому до появи шакалів
на кожній фермі на острові у нас було
майже по 200 овець
Тепер залишилося приблизно по 60 і то не
факт
помітив ще кілька своїх овець але щойно
вони відчувають його запах тікають
напівдики вівчарство немає майбутнього
каже Яків тепер він хоче все змінити
у вересні Ми почнемо ще раз заново тоді
я приведу 10 нових овець подивимося чи
вийде але далі не в такому обсязі ми
все-таки будемо тримати їх у хліву
Як ви мабуть доведеться звикнути жити із
шакалами схожам що вони прийшли сюди щоб
залишитися як нові жителі островів
[музика]
вони сподівалися на притулок і на шлях
до Євросоюзу
восени Минулого року на кордоні з
Польщею раптово з'явилися десятки тисяч
мігрантів зокрема з Близького Сходу
білоруський правитель Лукашенко вочевидь
навмисне підвівлі до кордону у відповідь
на Санкції ЄС проти білоруського режиму
польський уряд їх стримав з великою
кількістю поліції та колючим дротом
зараз на кордоні стоїть декілька
метровий паркан який посилено охороняють
тож мало кому вдається перетнути кордон
нелегально часто З останніх сил
у дорозі біля польської білоруського
кордону які донедав набув військової
зоною відчуження Маріус шукає у лісі
мігрантів які могли б перетнути кордон
дзвінки про допомогу надходять постійно
незадовго до нашої зустрічі каже Маріуш
Він допоміг ще одному хлопцеві із Гвінеї
його ноги були поранені дротяною
огорожею в нього глибокі рани інфіковані
нагноєні довелося все продезинфікувати і
обробити
маріушу дозволили знову проводити пошуки
безпосередньо біля кордону що я
полегшенням адже смугу завширшки понад 3
кілометри перегородили на більш ніж 9
місяців також і для таких волонтерів як
він
якщо нас активістів волонтерів там не
буде то мабуть більшість цих людей
загине в лісі
Бо деяких чоловіків та жінок справді
були в такому стані який важко описати
насправді регіон відомий своїми дикими
тваринами природою і лісом
але Територія була перегороджена тому що
Польща хотіла зупинити мігрантів
більшість із Близького Сходу які
перетинали кордон із Білорусі Зараз Там
стоїть новозбудований паркан
Я вважаю що така держава просто хоче
показати свою силу паркан можливо є
невеликим бар'єром але біженців все одно
через нього проходять зверху знизу не
існує стіни яка б зупинила людей що
тікають від смерті війни чи
переслідувань
Ми хочемо подивитися на прикордонний
паркан власними очима довжина майже 190
кілометрів висота 5 метрів вартові
камери за словами прикордонників зараз
до Польщі прибуває значно менше
мігрантів
помічаємо що не тільки ми а й інші
відвідують територію біля паркану через
її все ще незвичний та відчужений вигляд
у зоні відчуження знаходилося і село
Миньківці там був надзвичайний стан
відвідувачів Просто так не пускали А тих
хто хотів виїхати багаторазово
перевіряли
сади простягнулися аж до огорожі позаду
Білорусь союзниця Путіна питаємо про
паркан чи правильно що його побудували
якби не цей паркан росіяни вже були
перед нашими дверима це все готувалося
ще до конфлікту в Україні
ту ж саму думку ми чуємо і У крамниці на
колесах тітки Емми
зараз ми у безпеці добре що тут
збудували стіну і Ми дякуємо тим хто це
зробив
у маньківцях які в інших місцях
військові та прикордонники продовжують
все контролювати офіційно зона була
також призначена для захисту сил безпеки
та затримання контрабандистів які
переправляють мігрантів але Польщу
звинувачують у тому що вона всупереч
міжнародному право відправляли людей
назад до Білорусі так звані видворення
схвалив польський парламент
Ми їдемо далі у зону відчуження
потрапили 187 зокрема багато таких Які
фактично живуть з туризму як от кошеняни
тут проживає Лише кілька сімей переважно
польські татари мусульманська меншина
суботній ранок Чоловіки і жінки моляться
окремо
біля мечеті зустрічаємо це нету
Богдановича вона рада що у зону
відчуження нарешті скасували
було затишно тут не було жодної людини
взагалі тому Ми радіємо що тут нарешті
відбувається служба І що ми можемо разом
відзначити свято жертвопринесення і що
Життя продовжується
Вона веде нас до свого екскурсійного
ресторану через дорогу
великий заклад традиційна Татарська
Кухня 30 працівників
гості переважно туристи та постійні
клієнти яких тривалий час сюди не
пускали
було смачно нам запитує менеджер
ресторану як завжди чудово відповідає
відвідувачка нарешті тут знову з'явилися
гості після коронавірусних локдаунів
вони ледве не довели зону відчуження до
фінансового краху каже дзенетта
Богдановича і так у багатьох місцевих
підприємств
без зовнішньої допомоги ми вижити не
зможемо якщо отримаємо підтримку то
впораємося а якщо ні то навіть не
уявляємо що трапиться
але гроші не єдина проблема розповідає
жінка Зона відчуження вплинула б також і
на психіку і настійкість щоб допомогти
іншим сім'ям у цьому районі тепер вона
дозволяє малим крамницям виставляти біля
ресторану свої прилавки сила в родині
каже жінка тож треба триматися разом
хворобливий Шарм зруйнованих будівель
або ржавий дотик старих покинутих
фабричних цехів що людина зникає природу
відвойовується занедбані так звані
закинуті місця вони зачаровують
фотографа свена феміні із крефіда і не
лише його і у світлини знаходять свою
аудиторію і навіть дуже гарно поза як
той кому набридло робити селфі перед
типовою гірською чи пляжною панорамою
тепер шукають мотиви фонеми і тоді
ідилія зникає
якоюсь цікавою є ця історія яка заростає
травою Це була програма У фокусі Європа
від телекомпанії Deutsche Welle Дякуємо
за ваш інтерес до побачення
українською мовою озвучено центром медіа
ініціатив переклад Володимира та Олесі
Швед режисер Павло Тимченко так читали
Олена потоцька Юрій Лисенко та Олесь
гоян Київ 2022 рік